>> THIS IDEA THAT Y'ALL -- NOT
Y'ALL ONE POLL SHOWS 33%.
THE AVERAGE IS 44 -- 44, 45%.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN POLLS.
>> I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT THE
DISCONNECT IS BETWEEN THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
CONGRESS, AND SOME OF THE
POLLING AND ONGOING HAND HAND
RINGING.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT
DEMOCRATS WORRIED ABOUT
MIDTERMS?
[INAUDIBLE]
>>
>> Bret: WELL, DISCONNECT IS
THAT INFLATION IS RISING AND
INTEREST RATES ARE GOING UP AND
PEOPLE ARE FEELING IT.
IT SEEMS, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LATEST QUINNIPIAC POLL THE
PRESIDENT'S JOB APPROVAL RATING
33%.
IF YOU BREAK THAT DOWN HISPANICS
ARE AT APPROVAL OF 26%.
INDEPENDENTS 26%.
AGES 18 TO 34, 21%.
THE RCP REAL CLEAR POLITICS
AVERAGE DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY
27% SAY RIGHT DIRECTION, WRONG
TRACK 64.9.
AND THE AVERAGE ON THE ECONOMY
FOR THE APPROVAL 36%.
THIS IS AN AVERAGE OF RECENT
POLLS OF PRESIDENT BIDEN ON THE
ECONOMY.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE NOT GOOD
HEADING INTO A MIDTERM ELECTION
SEASON.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
GUY BENSON, POLITICAL EDITOR OF
TOWN HALL.COM.
HOST OF THE GUY BENSON SHOW.
LESLIE MARSHALL DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST AND SYNDICATED RADIO
HOST HUGH HEWITT.
HUGH, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SAYING AND DOING IN REACTION TO
SOME OF THESE NUMBERS?
>> WELL, THE REALITY OF THE
INFLATION NUMBER, BRET, AND THE
APP.ANCE OF THE PRESIDENT ARE
COLLIDING AND NOW IT'S A
QUESTION OF WHAT SINKS FASTER
THE PRESIDENT WANTS APPROVAL OR
THE RUSSIAN WARSHIP THAT WENT TO
THE BOTTOM TODAY?
GUY TWEETED OUT EARLIER TODAY
THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THOSE
NUMBERS YOU JUST PUT UP, IT'S
THE YOUNGSTERS, THE 18 TO
34-YEAR-OLDS HEMORRHAGING.
LATINO MAN AS WELL.
THE YOUNGSTER.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT AN
18-YEAR-OLD VOTER WHO DOESN'T
MUCH CARE FOR THE OPINIONS OF
HIS 38-YEAR-OLD PARENTS OR
58-YEAR-OLD GRANDPARENTS WHEN
THEY GET TO 78-YEAR-OLD
GREAT-GRANDPARENTS THEY LOSE
CONFIDENCE.
AND THE PRESIDENT WANTS FRAIL
APPEARANCE AND REALITY OF 8.5%
INFLATION IS JUST SLAUGHTERING
HIS APPROVAL RATING AND RIGHTLY
SO BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY THINGS
HE COULD DO THAT HE DOESN'T AND,
THEREFORE, THE PRICE THE
DEMOCRATS WILL PAY IN NOVEMBER
IS GOING TO BE STEEP.
>> Bret: LESLIE, OUR FRIEND TOM
BEVAN AT REAL CLEAR POLITICS,
YOU KNOW, WE ARE ALL A LITTLE
CYNICAL AT TIMES PREDICTION
BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING IS SO
LOW WITH 18 TO 34-YEAR-OLDS HE
WILL HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
FORGIVE A HUGE CHUNK OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT AFTER LABOR DAY TO TRY
TO HELP DEMS AVOID COMPLETE
DISASTER IN NOVEMBER.
BUY THAT?
>> I LIKE TOM AND I DON'T BUY
THE REASON FOR IT I MEAN,
STUDENT LOAN WAS SOMETHING --
STUDENT LOAN IS SOMETHING THAT
THE PROGRESSIVE FACTION OF MY
PARTY WANTED AND, YOU KNOW, AND
NOT JUST THE VOTERS AND NOT JUST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY STUDENTS THE
YOUTH OUT THERE.
THAT'S THE NUMBER THAT CONCERNS
ME, I MUST SAY BRET, A COUPLE,
INDEPENDENT AND YOUTH VOTERS IF
WE BREAK IT DOWN TO SUBURBAN
VOTERS WHO ARE INDEPENDENTS AND
AMONG THE YOUTH 18 TO
21-YEAR-OLDS THAT CONCERNS ME.
LOOK, MY PARTY HAS 90 DAYS TO
TURN THIS AROUND.
I KNOW WHAT HISTORY HAS SHOWN,
WHEN IT COMES TO WHOEVER IS IN
POWER AND WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
HOUSE AND HOW MANY SEATS YOU
LOSE.
I KNOW, I THINK WE TALKED THE
OTHER DAY ABOUT BIBLICAL
PROPORTIONS AND I CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT.
YOU KNOW, BUT I THINK A LOT OF
AMERICANS, YOU KNOW, ARE GOING
TO GO WITH WHAT THEY FEEL.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO IS IN
POWER.
THEY ARE GOING TO BLAME SOMEBODY
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BLAME THE
PARTY IN POWER.
EVEN THOUGH INFLATION, TO JEN
PSAKI'S POINT EARLIER, IS
MULTIFACETED.
THE GOVERNMENT DOES HAVE SOME
BLAME.
FEDERAL RESERVE HAS A LOT OF
CONTROL AND BLAME.
THEY WERE VERY PASSIVE AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE, MANY PEOPLE WERE
SAYING, ECONOMISTS WERE SAYING
RAISE INTEREST RATES BEFORE THIS
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE
CORPORATIONS.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, WE HAVE THE
PANDEMIC AND NOW YOU ADD
RUSSIA-UKRAINE TO THE MIX.
BUT, WE AS CONSUMERS, I KNOW I'M
GOING TO GET A LOT OF FLACK FOR,
THIS OKAY?
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GIRL, I
REMEMBER PICKING UP A LITTLE TEA
CUP MY GRANDMOTHER SAID MADE IN
CHINA, THAT IS JUNK, PUT IT
DOWN.
WE AS CONSUMERS NEED TO BUY
AMERICAN MORE AND THAT WILL PUSH
THESE CORPORATIONS TO STOP
OUTSOURCING AS MUCH AND PRODUCE
MORE AMERICAN GOODS HERE THAT
ARE GOING TO BE BETTER MADE AND
THEN WE ARE SUPPORTING PEOPLE
HERE THAT ARE MAKING THOSE
PRODUCTS RATHER THAN SUPPORTING
PEOPLE IN CHINA MAKING THOSE
PRODUCTS.
>> Bret: I DOUBT YOU WILL GET A
LOT OF PUSHBACK ACTUALLY.
GUY, ASSOCIATED PRESS, THINKING
SMALL BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SEARCHES FOR WAYS TO
BREAKTHROUGH.
HAVE IMPACT ON AMERICANS LIVES
FAR SHORT OF GOALS BIDEN SET ON
TAKING OFFICE.
PUT TOGETHER WHITE HOUSE IS
TRYING TO REGAIN MOMENTUM WHEN
THE BIDEN IS UNDER PRESSURE TO
RECALL GREAT AMBITIONS.
I NEVER REALLY UNDERSTOOD, GUYS,
WHEN HE CAME IN AND ALL THE
ARTICLES WERE BIDEN IS GOING TO
BE THE NEXT FDR.
EVEN WITH THESE MAJORITIES THAT
WERE SO SMALL IN THE HOUSE AND
THE SENATE, HE WAS GOING TO
SUDDENLY HAVE THESE BIG IDEAS
THAT CAME ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
AND IT NEVER HAPPENED.
>> WELL, TO USE A SPORTS ANALOGY
YOU WILL SOMETIMES HEAR ABOUT A
TEAM READING THEIR OWN
CLIPPINGS, READING THEIR OWN
PRESS STARTING TO BELIEVE IT AND
CUTTING CORNERS AND FAILING.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
BIDEN BELIEVED HIS OWN PRESS.
HE LIKED THIS NOTION OF BEING
THE NEXT FDR.
MAYBE MORE CONSEQUENTIAL THAN
BARACK OBAMA.
I MEAN, TRY IT, AND IT'S BEEN A
BIG FAILURE.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
TROTTING OUT LINES LIKE PUTIN
PRICE HIKE TO BLAME VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING ON.
THAT WAS ANYTHING BUT HIM I
DON'T HAVE THE ENERGY EVEN TO
REFUTE IT EVERY DAY BECAUSE IT
JUST ISN'T WORKING.
RIGHT, IF IT WERE ACTUALLY
GAINING SOME CURRENCY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, PERHAPS I WOULD
BE MORE CONCERNED.
BUT IT'S NOT.
AND I WOULD JUST DIRECT YOU TO A
PIECE TODAY IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," STEVEN RATTNER, MAJOR
ECONOMIST UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THIS IS
DEMOCRATIC ECONOMIST WHO LOOKED
AT THESE SITUATION RIGHT NOW, IS
HE WORRIED ABOUT A RECESSION
HEADING TOWARD 2024.
AND HE POINTS TO THE INFLATION
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW AND HE SAYS
THIS:  THIS IS QUOTING:  THIS IS
THE PRICE WE PAY FOR POOR
ECONOMIC POLICIES DELIVERED BY
THE WHITE HOUSE, BY THE
CONGRESS, AND BY THE FEDERAL
RESERVE.
AND HE CALLS THE $1.9 TRILLION
RESCUE ACT EXCLUSIVELY PASSED BY
DEMOCRATS, QUOTE:  AN
EXTRAORDINARY POLICY MISTAKE
THAT WILL GO DOWN IN HISTORY.
THAT'S AN OBAMA ECONOMIST JUST
SPEAKING THE TRUTH.
BIDEN CAN TALK ABOUT PUTIN UNTIL
HE IS BLUE IN THE FACE WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF INFLATION, MOST
VOTERS AREN'T BUYING IT.
>> Bret: MARK PENN, FORMER
CLINTON ADVISER SAYS HE SEES A
TORNADO AGAINST DEMOCRATS IN THE
MIDTERMS IF THESE NUMBERS
CONTINUE.
AND HE THINKS THEY WILL.
ALL RIGHT, HUGH, LAST THING.
I WANT TO JUST GET YOU REAL
QUICK ON TWITTER.
ELON MUSK JUST TWEETED OUT THIS
IF CURRENT TWITTER BOARD TAKES
ACTIONS CONTRARY TO SHAREHOLDER
INTEREST, THEY WOULD BE
BREACHING THEIR FIDUCIARY DUTY
THE LIABILITY TITANIC IN SCALE.
THIS IS QUITE SOMETHING TO WATCH
REALTIME TWEET BY TWEET, HUGH.
>> ON THE ONE SIDE THERE IS THE
PANIC ON THE LEFT WHICH IS
AMUSING.
ON THE OTHER SIDE THE RELATE IS
WHAT ELON MUSK JUST SAID.
CORPORATIONS OWE A FIDUCIARY
AREA DUTY TO THEIR SHAREHOLDERS
TO MAXIMIZE VALUE.
HE HAS PUT A VERY GOOD OFFER ON
THE TABLE IF THEY DON'T COME UP
WITH THE BETTER ONE THEY WILL BE
FLOODED RIGHTLY WITH LAWSUITS.
IT IS A SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
STORY.
IS HE RIGHT ON THE LAW.
>> SHAREHOLDERS OWN THE COMPANY
AND THE BOARD MUST ACT IN
RESPONSIBLE FASHION WITH CARE
TOWARDS ELON MUSK'S OFFER AND I
HOPE THEY D